did you ever think you make I
feel Victory I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value G values contagious
this world are entrepreneurs we get no
value to haters how run homie look what
I become I'm I'm the
one so podcast episode 3:26 we have the
man who uses Tik Tok and pisses other
people off he's not afraid of calling
people out he uh uh uh he apparently
calls someone a what a dick cheny and
3-in heels right and she corrected him
and said it's 5in heels and I still
don't know what the tweet's all about we
going to talk about that I I mean I have
no idea what the I had no idea what you
was talking about you called out two
people in heels from right that's
accurate yes but it was constant calling
out it's great to have you back man good
to be on brother yes how you doing you
feel good to be here I'm feeling good
I'm feeling pretty unconstrained and uh
how was dinner with uh your family and
Ron mcel last night you know it was well
she said she refused to pay the bill CU
she's not I'm going going to get another
scent from the RNC I saw that say that
can she say that I mean not legally I
mean if you think about your duty is not
your money yeah it's not your money
right and so I don't know people you
think people know what the what
story talking about right here people
know what we're talking an total
so so so just so people if they
didn't watch the debate the other night
or whatever I am a believer in
accountability okay so this woman is
appointed chair of the RNC Republican
National Committee in 2017 let's just do
the math it's not that complicated 2018
loss 2020 loss 2022 no Red Wave 2023 bad
trouncing
so insanity is expecting a different
conclusion unless you're going to make a
change this is the person who's running
the Republican National Committee so
that had happened the night before the
debate the 2023 troun sing so I went on
stage and say what nobody else every
other candidate supposed to delicately
tiptoe around the Gentile Norms of the
RNC and it's not like I surprised her
with this okay we actually I didn't I
haven't talked about this before so we
went we we had a we had a debate walk
through you kind of go through in the
morning of I'm not making this up it's
it's like I wish there was no cameras
around in there we can catch this she
comes in she's just like trying to give
me a hug I'm like I'll give you a
handshake and I was just like how you
doing and she's like she's like how are
you doing I was like not great I mean
the election didn't go very well last
night she not great given last night and
I'm not even kidding you here's what she
says what happened last night oh my God
God no I'm not I'm not kidding so I
thought she was joking so I'm just like
yeah she was like no but seriously what
happened last night and then she got
kind of combative about it who's around
when when this is happen oh like people
from NBC other like staffers from the
Republican party she want to give you a
hug you said I'll give you a handshake
yeah yeah I said I'll give you a
handshake have you guys had any Feud
prior to this or no no no but I'm just
I'm just I believe in well we have not
multiple
actually because because it's not
personal it's the failure of how she
leads this party I mean number one at
the start of this race I said release
the debate stage criteria so you don't
play games later I believe that played a
role and and she was just like no but
they actually released it earlier than
they did last time around because I
believe I called on them to so they
released it at least earlier so I gave
credit where credit was due when they at
least responded first she was like no
we're not going to do it we're we're
staying radio silent but I believe I had
an impact on that and I gave credit
where credit was due so that was that
Loop was closed then Fox calls me after
the second debate and Chris Christie and
say hey do you want to would you spar
with Chris Christie or have a dialogue
open dialogue since the second debate I
mean the unspoken reality is that was
useless so I said I would do it the
night before Ron McDaniel calls me on my
cell phone says you will be disqualified
from the next debate if you participate
in this discussion with Chris Christie I
said R how does this Advance the
interests of the GOP like like the GOP
voter base how is the GOP voter base
better off if we hear less debate
between the candidates explain that to
me she has no good explanation but
regardless that raised some of my recent
sparring with her in public but this has
nothing to do with me and her what
happened on the night before the debate
was the Republican Party nationally got
trounced and every destroyed Kentucky
totally destroyed Virginia I mean kind
of Ohio you just go these are red States
okay oh Kentucky and Ohio
certainly and so I'm walking in the this
is the morning after that trouncing this
is the chairwoman of the Republican
National Committee she's coming she's
like hey how are you I'm like I'll give
you a handshake she's like how you doing
I said not that well given that last
night didn't go very well she what
happened last night like Oblivion is she
saying it jokingly or she's saying it
almost angrily
right because cuz I was like sending go
like she's she's challenging me she says
well what happened last night oh okay
like what happened last night I don't
know what happened last night tell me
what happened last night and I'm just
like this is the person who's
accountable for running the Republican
party I said who lost the election she
said we have nothing to do with that
really I run the National Party these
are State racist we have nothing to do
with that so where's and and and then
and then says and and and then starts to
like escalate her voice and
says I refuse to follow on the SW for
this one I refuse to fall on the sword
for this one this is not my fault and
it's like okay clearly she's been she's
been criticized before you hit the
stages this happening oh this is like
early this is in the morning right like
prep you kind of go through they show
you where you're going to be standing
here's your microphone so that's where
this happens so it's not like I
surprised her on the stage all right she
knew where I'm at on this she had
already had a long morning with this
topic oh of course and should I mean she
2018 loss 2020 loss 20 22 no Red Wave
2023 trouncing total drubbing for the
Republican party this is the individual
who's the national chairwoman she runs
the entire Republican National Committee
where's the accountability so I get on
stage and you're getting some like you
know standard you know beaten dead old
horse Donald Trump Quest I said forget
that let's talk about what happened last
night because the last two elections
he's been out Republicans have gotten
TRS for different reasons so stop
blaming the boogeyman there's an
accountability problem within the
Republican party and so so I say on
stage that Ron McDaniel if she wanted to
come up on stage and I meant it if she
did want to come up on stage you know
debate stage time is valuable but I
would still yield my time to her if she
wants to use the microphone look the
American people in the eye and say she
resigns which would be good for the
Republican party and I believe she
should resign so what does she say so
then the Press reports there's people
apparently sitting in her row or behind
her Row in front of her where she is
think about this the neutral Arbiter of
the Republican National Committee later
in the debate when I'm sparring with
other candidates booing when I'm
speaking speak clapping against other
candidates when I when they're speaking
against me so she was booing who was
booing she's booing me at other points
in the debate and I don't care about
that but think about your dereliction of
Duty you're supposedly the neutral
Arbiter of the entire National
Republican party hosting a debate it's
like a referee cheering in the middle of
a game between two teams it doesn't make
sense like if you're if the referee is
like booing or hollering in favor of one
team or the other that's that's what
that looks like if she's the
then she's saying during the breaks this
as reported by the Press so I wasn't
there but it's apparently sources who
are around her reported by multiple
sources in the Press saying that I would
not get another scent from the
RNC yep so think about what that means
that means she believes that's her
money right she these are donations
she's collected from other people but
somebody said a mean thing about her and
it's not even a mean thing about her
someone said that we need accountability
in the Republican party that this person
who has failed us four times in a row
that there needs to be some
accountability she says if he says that
about me then this money that I have
been a steward for a fiduciary for that
I'm not going to give a sent to him
because he said something that I didn't
like about me that's a conflict of
interest so so then I get a question
after the debate uh in The Press Room I
don't know who it came from but I'm
presuming it's from you know one of the
RNC align people which is how come you
would go on rana's stage on her stage on
her stage is what they said on her stage
and criticize her like that my response
is that's not her stage and that's the
problem with this party it doesn't
belong to these corrupt
establishment political creatures it
belongs to the voters and the people of
this country and that's where the
Republican party is badly mixed up
question for you when so no dinner
didn't go
well but I assume you know her last name
her maiden name Romney yeah oh yeah I
think it uh I think I think she embodied
it let let me ask a question when she
says you can't you know go debate
Christie then how is she okay with the
santis debating Nome because it's
corruption man you think that's what it
is absolutely it's corrup because the
people who are propping up Ronda santis
like the super pack money all that's
that's doing up and this not I'm not
it's not criticizing Ron or not CRI it
has nothing to do with it's just the
system is there's tens and tens of
millions of dollars in a system where
supposedly the max you can give to a
campaign is 3,300 bucks the people who
have lobbied and gotten their special
favors from and it's not just Ron it's
the way politics works that those people
are the big donors to the Republican
party and Ron is debating another
candidate who's running for US president
that is called Gavin new the man who's
running for US president flying around
doing the funny thing about this is
Gavin Nome is not running for US
president in the same way that Ronda
Sanz was not running for US president
jaunting around on public money and
private jets on matters that have
nothing to do with the state that's what
Gavin Newsome is doing now and as I said
on the debate stage as well to the
Democratic party man I call it
Republicans Democrats evenly call
Democrats
more be honest Joe Biden's not gonna be
the nominee so who's it going to be put
up whichever other person it's going to
be so we can have an honest debate but G
but Ron is able to have that full-on
debate on the same Network FOX but if
they're calling me I think what happened
is at a certain point in the race you
know around late summer initially
they're saying oh yeah young guy okay
check the box we got you know a lot of
boxes he checks for us we get to say
that that this guy ran in the Republican
Party young guy different generation
first generation whatever okay we check
that box oh wait he's he's not going
away when he's supposed to right the
other no-name candidates and I was
initially a no-name candidate too the
other no-name candidates had no chance
of making the first debate they're all
off nobody really paid attention to them
wait this guy's sticking around and then
wait he's saying some things that the
establishment that has an allergic
reaction to Trump wait he sounds a
little bit like that no this isn't
supposed to happen again no stop it okay
okay it was cute well it lasted like
make it stop that's sort of where they
were and so I think there has been a
concerted effort amongst the donor
establishment class that has convened
private Summits with the Haley campaign
the danis the Scott campaigns Pence and
others Christie I'm the only person
other than Trump that's not you know
invited to these closed door forums
there's certain debates we want Ronda
santis to get his airtime you do it
we're going to disqualify you from the
next debate and and then you get to the
place where now if you're critical of
that party she says we're not going to
you that she because she doesn't like
what I said it's a personal conflict of
interest is going to say you don't get
another scent from the RNC so in a
certain sense they prove my point about
the corruption to say that they view
this as their money to treat it in a way
that they're going to pick whoever their
favorite horses are yeah that's that's a
that's very strange for because the
voter I'm sitting there saying why is
and I even asked the governor I said why
are you debating Nome I think a year ago
made sense I think right now makes no
sense for the two of you guys to debate
but but Rob do you have the clip of Ron
McDaniel being confronted about what
vivec said and what her response is and
she said I'm not the one running for
president and play this clip if you
could there were allegations uh that
were thrown on the stage by number one
of the candidates in particular arguing
that the Republican party has a culture
of boing specifically vasami called for
you to resign would you like to respond
to that I'm going to focus on beating
Joe Biden I I wish that's what all the
candidates did I'm not running for
president I'm very proud of the fact
under my tenure we won back the house we
now are getting investigations into the
bidens I also as Michigan chair for the
first time in 30 years won a state that
Democrats hadn't been in I'm very proud
of the fact that we're going to have
staff in 15 states heading into 2024 but
you know I'll leave other people to
attack Republicans I'm going to focus on
Democrats I will say this we can't
attack each other and win we need all of
us so it at this point com which really
funny I so I I hadn't seen this
interview I saw a different interview
she did on Fox or Fox Business where
literally that was yesterday morning
she's going on Air National conservative
audience and said and and literally just
stated as a fact that VI voted for
Obama oh yeah that's that was that's
right 100 I I just confirm it for you
100% false never voted for Obama in my
life so you have the chair of the RNC
saying I'm not going to criticize the
Republicans then go on go on national TV
say one of the Republican presidential
candidates who you were booing middle of
the debate oh you have that one it's 11
seconds you can play the
clip you guys already yeah I saw it
after you actually uh there's so so that
was press reports of people who were
sitting in her row commenting on the
fact that she said that there's going to
be not one cent to me from the RNC
fiduciary violation this money think
situation this not one cent how does it
actually get divvied up because you're
the only candidate out there that has
made their money as an entrepreneur you
don't need their money tell you the
truth I have no idea how the hell all of
this sausage making works because I've
basically said screw the system now I'm
that what does that cost me eight figure
sums of my wealth that we're putting
into this campaign 15 16 plus million
bucks already putting in millions more
it's going to be tens of millions of
dollars certainly by the time we're done
we're going to stop at nothing but
that's the cost of saying screw you to a
corrupt system that otherwise wants you
to behave like their circus monkey which
I refuse to but the point is this is a
person who's running their managing
other people's money and saying that
because you said something I don't like
I'm not going to give you one cent then
goes on national TV and spew I it's just
a straight up factual falsehood right VI
voted for Obama is it false yes it is is
it damaging yes it is is it done with
malicious intent for the person who was
booing at me and saying those things yes
it was now am I going to go after
because I have better things to do in my
life probably not right but this is this
is corrupt stuff well in the first play
this real quick because it's 11 seconds
go ahead Rob I know V's kind of newer to
the party he voted for Obama so he may
not know that look her she just flat out
says I voted for a lie I mean look at
this woman bold face getting up there
loses four elections for the Republican
Party pathetically going up literally
just looking the American voters
Republican voters in the eye and telling
them a boldfaced lie you just just play
that I just want people to H it clip
again cuz I don't want that that I'm
putting words in her mouth I know V's
kind of newer to the party he voted for
Obama so he may not voted I mean this is
that is a lie this woman a fact without
with an iota of basic is way to prove
that so she loses yeah actually actually
there's a way to prove it okay has
voting record the fact yeah the voting
record so so actually I was so
disillusioned and I've talked about this
I voted libertarian when I was young in
my first election then I got so
disillusioned from politics that it's
actually public record that in both of
those I don't like John McCain and I
don't like Barack Obama and I didn't
like Mitt Romney and I didn't like
Barack Obama so I actually didn't vote
in those elections I sat him out I'm not
I'm not PR ularly proud of that it was
my 20s I understand why many people are
disillusioned from politics I was
disillusioned back then too I voted for
the libertarian candidate back in 2004
and then I basically said screw this
this is a this is a I have better things
to do with my life I'm going to be an
entrepreneur I could care less about
politics but then came back around to it
later but literally that is that is now
public record actual
false lie yep flat boldface lie to the
American people say they won't give
money and so that that proves the
corruption so that's the Ron McDaniel
corruption but then I decided when I was
on stage okay I'm wasting too much time
on this on this stuffed suit of a
bureaucrat running the RNC let's focus
on the real problem which is the
equivalent the Ron McDaniel of of media
there's many of them Christen Welker
sitting right there from NBC News and
there's a connection between the two
because who
decides to put up the Christen wers of
the world to moderate a republican
debate it's none other than the RNC the
failed establishment that Ron McDale has
run that's lost its last four major
Cycles relative to what it was supposed
to do so that same it's almost proof
sitting on that stage but back to people
saw the rest of that so so that's why I
mean it's it was almost they're
repeatedly proving my point based on the
kind of debate they were hosting and the
moderators they hired to the things
she's saying in the audience during the
debate to booing me during the debate to
now saying that false things are who you
think would be a good RNC who would be a
good R any question yeah so I I so let's
Kirk said you would be somebody like you
would be very good so Kirk said I'm not
I'm not I'm look I'm I'm in this to be
the president of the United States I
think that I can lead the country best
in that position but Charlie said that
about me yeah well I'll return the
compliment to him I think he could
actually do a good job of
it think I don't think it's crazy
actually I mean he's a from a different
generation they would not let him do it
I mean this that's almost a credential
so whoever they shouldn't let do it that
should be a requirement for whoever does
do it to actually get put in that place
I mean harmy Dylan very good she ran
against Ron McDaniel she's competent
she's is a lawyer she understands and I
think the lawyer thing helps because
there's a there's an element to running
the elections in a way that's
competitive that you make sure it's
actually run fairly for the Republicans
to be able to compete so harid Dylan has
a good background there's this guy Scott
presler who's I don't know if he's he's
a republican activist he's nowhere on
the radar of the Republican National
Committee but he's a guy who I've gotten
to know talked to him from time to time
was tried to be very helpful in some of
the other elections that have played out
in the last couple of years but a
Grassroots Act that has focused on the
way ele are run so Scott presler hary
Dylan I mean these are all good people I
mean I I um I I assume Charlie wasn't
serious when he said yes to me but I
would I would say in the simil I think I
saw somewhere him saying by the did you
have that there's a video of you talking
to somebody were you talking to her or
no at the end of the debate that's
somebody else I I don't I to my
knowledge I haven't talked to ra since
after the debate there's a lot of people
piling in so if she was in that throng
scream something senselessly I have no
idea whether this the part that's very
confusing for me I want to I want to
play this and then we can go to a bunch
of different topics we got time Rob pull
up the three polls so there's three
polls I want to show you okay first one
go to the uh uh and by the way before we
go to this poll let's go to our sponsor
because we haven't done that yet Rob
let's go to our sponsor and then right
after this I'm going to show you three
polls each of them are contradictory of
each other then I want to get your
thoughts go ahead Rob so look I've been
in the financial industry since 911 the
day before 911 and I've owned stocks
bonds mutual funds real estate crypto
gold you name it I've owned it but the
one thing that's very important part of
my portfolio all these years is gold I
love having a percentage of my network
in Gold that I have access to in case of
many different things that's why we
chose to work with our new sponsor
American Harford gold if you have
retirement funds that you cannot afford
to lose American hardford Gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American hardford gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback commit
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on a link in the
description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 okay Rob are we back on okay if
we're back on so here's what I want to
show you I want to show you three polls
okay and one of them may or may not be a
poll and and we'll get your thoughts on
it so first that's going around here's
uh New York Times okay who did well in
the in the debate I was about to say
podcast so did better score 10 Niki
Haley then they have the santis then
they have Chris Christie then they have
Tim Scott then they have you last okay
yep now keep in mind this is New York
Times let's go to the next one and it's
not a poll you know that right yeah
that's opinion that's their opinion go
back to go back to it go back to it I
was I want to make sure that's right
yeah opinion writers and cont so their
own opinion writing and contributors
their own staff who writes for which is
great by the way but by the way to me to
me I see this as flip it is how I see it
but go to the next one go to this is
David Pacman you've been on a show and I
thought it was a very good show the two
of you guys together this guy's a
far-left hardcore liberal guy he thinks
Biden's doing a fantastic job I talk to
the left I like talking and I thought it
was a very good conversation with the
two of you at the bottom here is Tim
Scott okay then it's Des santis then
it's you then it's Chris
by way the weird Democrats 37,000 V this
isual VES on Twitter are choosing Nikki
Haley then Chris Christie you in the
middle this is how I process this on New
York Times They want him last on a David
Pacman they have you right in the middle
and they won the santis last second to
the last and Tim Scott okay so not go to
a poll that we ran and this sample size
to by the time it ended ended up being
165,000 votes votes 83% you then the
santis then Haley then Tim Scott we're
capitalists so you know our audience is
going to be an audience that you are
business owners entrepreneurs guys who
like running businesses conservative
ideas but this one has you first the
Santa second Haley third Tim Scott we
didn't put Chris Christie because he
just wasn't fighting I thought he was
just kind of lobbying for a job so how
do you process when you read all these
articles New York Post here's what New
York Post said about you I didn't see
that one okay well let's read it if you
can pull this up Rob Republicans debate
verdict impressive Haley shines stupid
vivec self-destruct okay this is the PO
the post impressive Haley and stupid you
know it's
interesting you know I I I would um I
would take a lot of criticisms and and
it's a fascinating one it's never before
other than in the media's and Nikki
Haley's assessments of me last time she
called me in the last debate she said I
feel Dumber every time I hear you speak
is what she said last time if you
actually think about that I understand
why she feels that way but that's the
the the the the dumb or the stupid
criticism it's that's a new one for me
you know and this in in presal I mean
you were valid Victorian you went to
Harvard you went to Y have you ever been
called Stupid in your life that's not a
word iate like new experiences so it's
interesting you you know what this does
though you know what this does to me
there's so many other adjectives or
words you can use than that you lose
credibility using a word like that and
this is New York post is the oldest
that's been around for God knows how
long so why would they you're a
conservative okay you're calling out
anti-establishment doesn't this almost
position New York Post as establishment
but New York Post is as establishment so
who do you think they're for they have
they phase one of the campaign they were
for Ronda sandis phase two of the
campaign they've decided they're for
Nikki Haley that's the answer and and
the Really thing they're against is
Trump or anything resembling what Trump
was for this country Allin in some ways
and I and I respect and admire the New
York Post for its reporting when the
hunter B laptop story came out that was
suppressed and so you know it's a paper
that is founded by Alexander Hamilton
there's a there's a lot that I've liked
about it when they're going against the
establishment of the left but the fact
of the matter is they are the
establishment just with the conservative
Sheen and they've gone all in and I
think that here's the third rail for
them I I've realized this if you're
doing the woke anti-woke stuff and
whatever you know I mean I wrote this
book they've given me you plenty of
favorable coverage when I'm talking
about domestic issues related to being
anti-woke it's like yes we're in for
that Crusade good and I actually exposed
a lot of the illegality of the way their
own stories were suppressed about hun
Biden but the real third rail is foreign
policy if you're giving up on the
interventionist
neoconservative model of liberal
hegemony that's the real third rail for
these people and so when I've touched
that third rail and Trump touched that
third rail as
well then it's gloves off game over
because that threatens the existence of
their very identity source of power and
for people like Nikki Haley the source
of money so that's what I've realized in
this campaign is that I thought a few
years ago like when I wrote this
book woke Inc I thought I was hitting
the third rail it felt like it right I
was I was a guy who was running a
business you know and it's funny these
you know that's I'll put some of these
other recent attacks to inside they're
not important this clown called Chris
cunu a man who is a governor of governor
of newshire of New Hampshire but is is
another establishment creature is um you
know believes that somebody who speaks
with the cander that I did on that stage
does not reflect the temperament to be
president give me a break I mean these
people are these people are all
different versions of the same thing
showing up in different stuff suits
somewhere heels somewhere different
kinds of heels male heel man heels and
women heels but they're they a bunch of
stuffed suits with the same thing inside
it's Dick Cheney 2.0 but when I wrote
that book I felt like I was hitting the
third rail as a c o calling out the woke
cancer and it and it was at the time now
it's easy much easier to criticize
wokeness than it was back then this is
in the aftermath of George Floyd's death
but actually here's what I've learned in
this campaign that wasn't really the
third rail the third rail is really
going heavy
on Clarity that the US should not be
electing to enter Wars that war should
never be a preference only a necessity
that the sole obligation of a US policy
maker is to US citizens here in American
soil period not to some other person in
another country that the corruption is
bipartisan and that the super Pacs are
cancer in American politics I mean if
you're hitting these points that's the
real third rail for the establishment
they're happy with people going hard on
anti-woke at least from the right-wing
version of The Establishment and that's
been one of my learnings in this
campaign is what you think is the third
rail and you're riding it if they're if
they're really still propping you up
you're not really hitting the third rail
you're not really really get into the
depth of talking about what others
aren't willing to talk about but it's I
just was speaking my convictions as it
relates to the war in Ukraine which I
think has been a corrupt intervention
and something that has not Advanced us
interests that's really where we we say
oh no no no hold on hold the phone make
sure this guy we suppressed this guy in
a way that to bring It full circle was
the way that we were suppressed when we
when we reported on the 100 B laptop
story so it's interesting how that kind
of comes full circle but that's where we
are today why do you think they jump
ship from R Sanz to Nikki Hal like you
said the first part of the election
verus the second part she's been very
hawkish I think it just became quickly
evident that Ronda santis momentum has
no well yeah I mean he he he has no
chance they've concluded I think
correctly I mean I think the same is
true about Nikki Haley too but it became
so obvious that with that much money
behind him I we're talking like Mega
amounts of money that have never been
spent in a Republican primary before if
that couldn't lift up this dead weight
that's still hanging on the ground then
okay that's a lost cause let's just find
the the next puppet we can prop up and
you know I think that Nikki Haley came
out to be actively proar I mean there's
a woman who calls her heels ammunition
this is a woman who you know I think
when she come I mean I felt like saying
on the stage you know I'm not some third
world nation that you want to come bomb
right that's that's that's what she sees
the bombs explode her bank account grows
that's the kind of person that says okay
if she has really greased the wheels of
her own bank account to do the thing
that we want America to be doing that's
our new puppet she has no chance right I
mean This Woman's going absolutely
nowhere in this election but it's the
new thing that the establishment has
chosen to see if they can't pour the
same cash that they were throwing at
Ronda santis to prop up this new puppet
and you know I think this one's worse
than the than the Ronda santis puppet
Ronda S I wouldn't call him corrupt
right I I actually think he was a good
Governor I think he's a good dude
actually like at his at his heart as his
family is a good family I think he's
been exploited I think that's actually
what's happened here is this man would
have just continued being the governor
of this state and probably done a pretty
good job of
it and then the establishment decided
say no no no that's not your choice you
will be the chosen one to run for
president you don't think he wanted to I
don't think he wanted to really no I
don't think so I don't think so I mean I
I I ien you know I'm giving you my
opinion on this I certain things I can
tell you a hard facts everything we've
talked about so far about Ron McDaniel
on all that corruption that's hard fact
now I'm just giving you my opinion here
I don't think
he I don't think he in his heart would
have wanted to do this or felt called to
do that I think he was dragged into this
and it was a form of sort of abuse of a
guy who wasn't wired for this right I
mean he doesn't have the personality for
it he's not I don't think that he has a
personal appetite for it I think he
cares about the country I think that he
has you know he served the country in
the military as a lawyer and otherwise
he seems he seems to be a service
oriented person I think he was doing a
good job in Florida I think he cares
about Florida you know I think once they
started putting them up to this then it
changes your mentality and you use
Florida as a pedestal to then achieve
National ambition but him left to
himself without the establishment
taining him he would have just been
another of you know many good Governors
across the country and that's the right
role for someone like him or he's an
Executor you know in some ways people
use this
expression and they meet it as a slight
you know he's about somebody they could
say he's all talk no action in some ways
Ronda sis was for a while all action and
no talk and and I don't mean that as a
negative that could you could take that
as a positive but when you're talking
about running for president of the
United States you have to be able to
articulate a vision of who we are and
where we're headed that's part of the
job and that's not a guy who has it but
they propped him up they forced him into
it but I would not I would not call him
really you know corrupt I think he has
to dance to the tune of his donors just
cuz that's the way the game is played
and it's the mother's milk of politics
and so he does that like any other
puppet would
but the person who's actually corrupt in
this like outright corrupt is Nikki
Haley really yeah she's corrupt and and
in the way that like Joe Biden is
corrupt is that when you said you made
money with Boeing board M just kind of
go through the facts here right let mean
just like this is not this is somebody
privately benefiting from their public
service right this is wrong it's wrong
when Hunter Biden does it oh by the way
all these people including niiki Haley
will talk about Hunter Biden interesting
how that works Joe Biden's son she's
happy to talk about him without talking
about the corruption in her own family
so she she's South governor of South
Carolina does special favors for this
company called Boeing her entire time
while she's in
office after her time in public service
she has a nice little cush board seat
ready warm waiting for her at
Boeing a private company a private
company flies around a private jet I
think it was a some some nephron
pharmaceutical some pharmaceutical
company I forget what name it was i'
never heard of it's not even some major
company and I was come from that
industry but it's some random company
that's getting I don't know what the
name of it is
um that I haven't heard of it's okay but
flying her around on their private jet
making their private jet available to
her get State contracts from that
governor and I could go on I mean this
is just a consistent pattern okay this
person has repeatedly milked and done
favors for people who have scratched her
back she does her shortlived you know
cup of coffee stint at the UN okay very
shortlived St her real foreign policy
experience wasn't her time at the UN it
was the millions she made afterwards
after she steps down her family starts a
military Contracting firm Allied defense
LLC if the mainstream press were doing
decisions Allied defense should have to
disclose who their clients are I did
something that no normal business people
don't do I've put up 20 years of my tax
records personal tax filings she should
put up 20 years of her personal tax
filings and put up the C clients of
Allied defense LLC if you're running for
US president tell us who the damn
clients are of the military contractor
that you started presumably using your
connections from the UN starts the
military Contracting firm starts again
then serving on the board of Boeing ends
up giving secretive speaking fees from
foreign actors while also running a
military Contracting firm think about
that it's Hillary Clinton on steroids
you could just go down the list she's
somebody who literally during this
presidential campaign as far as I know
it's unprecedented in US presidential
election history collecting corporate
stock options while running for US
president and now she's a
multi-millionaire and by the way what I
left out was at the time she left the UN
she and her family were drowning in
debt by the way for somebody who's an
accountant that's a discussion for
another day but goes from being and
wants to run the US and says that she's
the candidate who's going to fix our
national debt problem comes out of
government drowning in personal
debt uses connections to start start a
military Contracting firm without naming
their clients somebody who actually then
joins the board of Boeing the company
who's backi scratched forever well
Governor South Carolina another military
contractor speaking fees including with
foreign actors Hillary Clinton style
collecting stock options while running
for US president all of that then
emerges just like Joe Biden a
multimillionaire these are not the
people whether it's Biden or Haley these
are not the people we should want
deciding whether to send your kids to
die fighting somebody else's War it's
disqualifying the very least be
transparent about it and then you get to
the question of the press where is the
Press asking the questions okay what are
the clients of Allied defense
LLC is it's a dereliction of your duty
as the pre as as the certainly
conservative press to ask that basic
question why shouldn't the American
people know who are the clients of the
military Contracting firm that her
Fortune bumps up Eightfold becomes a
multi-millionaire exploiting her
connection ctions at the time at the UN
now running to be commander-in-chief on
a hawkish worldview marching us into
World War III we deserve to know and yet
the same establishment that props up Ron
McDaniel as the chair of the RNC the
same establishment that hires the likes
of christen Welker to run that debate
the same establishment that tried to
prop up Ronda santis but realized that
even reams of millions could not lift up
that dead weight so now has shifted to
Nikki Haley does not want other people
like me asking that question which is
why they're so Keen to silen me
and that's why she called you scum oh
yeah I think it's a lot of projection
going on there yeah cuz you're CU you
the you Hur the wallet though if you
think about it uh VC that everybody in
that stage was proar and and Pat made a
point about a month ago when you see
yeah when you see when you see a
hospital effect all those rooms they're
in business they need sick people to be
in there we need a warant and it's a
conflict of if interest if you're a
defense Contracting your whole family
her husband Michael Haley owns one it's
would you you become president of fact
would you would you put legislation to
like not that all of this corruption
should be banned you should not be a to
Lobby the government for 10 years until
after you've left the government if you
have regulated a company or done a deal
with a company as you do in South
Carolina with Boeing you absolutely
should never be able to join the board
of that company certainly not for 10 or
20 years okay you shouldn't be able to
trade individual stocks at with your own
individual investment discretion if
you're a congressman or regulator of
that specific industry yeah or nany
Pelosi but but here's the thing man I
cuz I have been very critical of like
the corrup Democratic establishment the
Pelosi the bidens the Hillary clintons
of the world but I can't do that with
credibility if we have the same problem
in our own house but then you're not
supposed to talk about it okay and
here's the thing that you know the
Republican party claims to be the party
that is against identity politics I
there's an unspoken rule in the
Republican party that if you have two ex
chromosomes you got to be careful about
going after her and I get that I mean
the political Consulting class tells
tells me that as well in the first
couple debates yeah I probably got the
bad advice but you know she's been I
mean she's called me four-letter words
each of the last few debates but there's
a certain thing if you have two ex
chromosomes somehow you're immune from
criticism that's not what the Republican
Party stands for identity politics if
you're running for US president you
can't handle the heat you stay out of
the kitchen you want to sit across the
table from xiin ping you better be able
to confront basic questions like your
tax returns or how you made your money
or who the clients of Allied defense LLC
are and how that relates to your foreign
policy that frankly makes more money by
taking us to War I think that these are
real questions we got to get into let's
let's talk foreign policy let's talk
foreign policy so Israel Hamas Palestine
you're seeing what's going on there
numbers being reported what's taking
place eron's coming out saying he's
declaring Israel war criminals as turkey
rallies behind Hamas we're seeing the
protesting all over the place you're
seeing US forces Under Fire in the
Middle East as America slides towards
Brink a defective uh drone launched by
an Iranian backed militia targeted US
forces at the air air base in Iraq but
failed to detonate sparring casual
sparing casualties this incident was one
of 40 drones and Rocket attacks on US
troops by Iranian back militias in
response to American support for Israel
during the Gaza War we we can keep
hearing about these stories one
open-ended question what's your position
with what's going on here how would you
if you were the president right now how
would you put a stop to this so there's
so much to talk about here uh we got
time though yeah good this isn't cable
news I like this no it's not it's good
so there's no buzzer that goes off in 30
seconds no you mean that okay yes and
and and this is what uh this is why this
new media is important by the way is
they hate that I come on these kinds of
I mean I go on all these podcasts so
something that we'll say here here's how
it works here's the game plays cable
news does not like that you all exist
and so they create a disincentive for
candidates like me to come on here why
they're going to take something I say
here happens every time airlift it out
of the context of the conversation that
we're having and then put it on the
three minute or two-minute version that
they have or 32 version that they have
which is their mode of media and they
know that that purposefully distorts
what the candidate says which creates a
disincentive for candidates to actually
engage in real human conversation and
that's why other people even when they
show up in podcasts are com in in you
know stuff suits that being said let's
talk about foreign policy because this
is the third
rail so here's my
view my job as US
president is to look after the interests
of Americans here in the Homeland I
don't think that should be controversial
but that's my view I think the job of
Israel's president is to look after the
citizens of
Israel and I think that we're an ally of
Israel and what do we do as an ally of
Israel I think it is to provide
diplomatic support without military
intervention and so all of the stuff
about sending this kind of Aid or that I
think it's better for Israel and better
for the United States if we mind our
Affairs and they mind theirs but we give
them the Diplomatic support they need to
say you get to do whatever you need to
to defend your Homeland I think that's
what I said on the stage I mean you I
would if I was on the phone with BB I'd
tell them you know what if you need to
smoke the terrorists at your Southern
border that are invading and threatening
your country you go do that and I'm
going to be smoking the terrorists that
are trying to smoke this country on our
Southern border if they're entering here
and attacking our country in the same
way that they're attacking yours that's
what I'm going to do you do you and
we'll give you the Diplomatic support
without the UN or anybody else second
guessing your decisions and
micromanaging you or us micromanaging
you and I think that's part of the where
we muddy the
waters is when we give them some kind of
check but then we have to then become
the backseat driver the armure
quarterback and then also have to assume
and bear implicit responsibility for
what does or doesn't happen I don't
think that's good for the US and I don't
think that's good for Israel and
actually you know I want people to
understand this the founding vision of
Israel the the George Washington Figure
in Israel was a guy by the name of David
benan he's the founder of Israel the
whole premise in the founding of Israel
he said basically words to this effect
he was an eloquent man about 5 feet tall
but a big man a mighty man who said we
don't want to depend on the sympathies
of the west or anybody else or the
United States or anybody else I want a
country where we will defend our own
existence without depending on anybody
else to do it that was the premise of
Israel so I think that this whole idea
now as US president I think it's totally
messed up that we're giving foreign a to
any country whose national debt per
capita is less than ours but from an
even Israel
perspective that was the founding vision
of Israel itself so my view on here's
what I would do is let Israel do
whatever Israel needs to do to defend
itself my job as the US is to look after
American interests we will give them
diplomatic support to be able to do that
but don't intervene militarily and that
makes it clear to Iran so I can say
publicly to Iran you stay the hell out
and we'll stay out and we'll let the IDF
get its job done in the meantime because
you read some of those headlines if you
hit us the United States of America if
you hit our sons and daughters on
military bases our troops who are
serving this country if you actually hit
them we will hit you whoever that is
whichever group that is we will hit that
group back the person who actually hit
us 10 times harder is against the
backdrop of my view that we shouldn't be
in places like Syria and Iraq in the
first place we were told we left Syria
and Iraq now we find out we've got what
thousand couple thousand people in
places that we were told that we were
left sitting there as sitting ducks and
targets to get hit so that should have
been there in the first place but I'm
always pro-american here if you hit us
we will hit you
back but what's interesting is there's
also an interesting story I don't know
any when Trump gave the speech it was in
Texas recently I want to say say what he
recounted I think an interesting story
that went under reported you guys could
probably find it and pull it up at some
point um it was interesting where he
told the story of after they took out
solomani the
Iranians gave him a message or gave the
you know White House a message that Hey
listen we have to have pride here we're
going to hit back but we're not actually
going to hit you we're going to send
some
missiles but it's not going to hit
anything and that's exactly what
happened these are like very precise
missiles they send up and then they
explode in the air without hitting their
actual targets when in fact these are
very reliable precise missiles so in a
certain sense and that was interesting
it was fascinating he he hadn't told
that story before I hadn't I mean I
think certainly the government hadn't
told that story
before and so it's interesting where the
responsible job of a US president is to
advance our interest to be strong to
protect Americans but it's not in our
national interest to automatically
Sleepwalk our way into World War II so
for the people who are saying that
because Iran funds you know Hamas or
hezbo or the houis or other
groups and those groups hit Israel that
that gives the US a reason like the
Lindsey Grahams of the world that make
this argument to preemptively strike
Iran think about that
logic according to that logic of proxy
Warfare Russia would have the right to
hit the United States now because we're
funding Ukraine to hit Russia so those
messed up theories of proxy war that's
how you get to World War I and I think
it is a vital National interest so we
have this we have this thing I rolled
out the night before the debate it's our
no to neon's pledge actually people
should go there we're not asking for
money or anything else just sign the
pledge if you're on board no to neoc
cons. okay and every person who is a
political appointee in my Administration
will have to sign it yeah there's it is
there's the no neocons pledge noon.com
you go there look just scroll down this
is not controversial stuff if you scroll
down to the the three elements of this
pledge avoiding World War III is a vital
National
objective maybe Nikki Haley agrees with
me on that disagrees with me on that but
I think most people agree with me on
that war is never a preference only a
necessity well for those for whom war is
a preference you know from Carl Rove to
you know John Bolton to yeah Lindsey
Graham to Nikki Haley they will disagree
on that where never a preference only a
necessity okay that's number two number
three is the sole Duty of US policy
makers is to US citizens so again these
things should not be controversial but I
will require any political
appointee in my Administration to make
sure they're aligned with these three
elements of a basic foreign policy
Vision but that's that's what puts me at
odds with most of the Republican Party
how close are we I I think we're closer
than we've ever been in our lifetime
Patrick in In Our Lifetime okay I got
you and so so you know where you sit
down and you you rent a company you're
like okay we're negotiating with XYZ uh
we want the price to be this if we push
a little too much they may walk away we
don't want them to walk we want them to
stick around how far do we want to go
what's the risk we want to do and are
you kind of making decisions what could
tip them off what could cause them to do
something if you were to say this could
cause World War I these three things
could cause World War II what would
those things be so I'll give you a
couple like principal answers and I'll
give you a couple fact answers sure the
principal answer how you get to world
war is World War is rarely it's it's
never in the interest of any of the
countries who enter it so that means you
it's a trip wire that accidentally
forces a bunch of people into a
situation that's not actually in their
individual interest you could call it a
collective action
problem here's how World Wars happen
vague red
lines so when you don't know what
somebody's actual red lines are then you
accidentally end up doing things that
cross somebody's Red Line without
knowing it so my view is the us has
operated according to this model of
strategic ambiguity I think we need
strategic
Clarity be crystal clear and mean it as
I said if you hit us including our sons
and daughters who are troops stationed
wherever they are we will hit you not
some other vague other actor we will hit
you 10 times harder that's a clear red
line that's how you avoid world wars now
I think the other thing you got to look
at
is is it my job
to be a global policeman if so that that
that's a clear path to World War because
you have conflicts that don't relate to
your self-interest or is it my path only
to look after my self-interest so if you
start with the first premise that it's
in everybody's every nation's
self-interest to avoid World War and
every nation is only acting in their
self-interest then you avoid that world
war scenario so now let's get really
specific what are the series of events
that could lead us
here one thing we're doing right now
that increases the risk of world war is
that our policies are driving Russia
further into China's
hands and in order to have a World War
what you need is two different super at
least two different superpowers neither
of whom can obviously Prevail in victory
over another one I think that the US
Visa China alone or the US Vis Russia
alone actually is objectively going to
be stronger than each alone but if
Russia and China are Allied
as we're forcing them to be and I'll
explain how then they could arguably
outmatch the United States because
Russia has nuclear capacity ahead of
that of the US Russia has Hypersonic
missile capabilities ahead of that of
the US what does Hypersonic missile
travel faster than the speed of sound
carrying potential nuclear loads that
could hit the United States China's
Naval capacity is arguably ahead of that
of the United States and we then depend
on China's economy for our modern way of
life and so China and Russia are already
in Alliance with one another but we're
we're driving Russia further into
China's hands how by isolating Russia
economically so they need more China if
we if we've cut off the West they need
to actually depend on China economically
how we're arming Ukraine to the teeth to
fight Russia that's why China's arm I
mean to arming Ukraine that's why
China's then arming Russia again driving
them further into China's hands
militarily economically and militarily
the policies we have adopted are driving
Russia further into its military
alliance with China we made a commitment
James Baker the US sec secary of state
did in 1990 to gorbachov who led the
USSR that NATO would expand not one inch
it's like it's like Ron McDaniel's not
one cent commitment to me not one inch
past East Germany well we've we haven't
kept that NATO's expanded more after the
fall of the USSR than it has ever after
again then encircling Russia or at least
from Putin's perception driving then
further into a need for military
alliance with China so that's the number
one precipitating factor here is the
Russia China Alliance that raises the
risk of World War III and then if you
combine that with these vague rules of
proxy war right the vague rules of proxy
war are well we're saying in the Middle
East that if somebody pays a group to
hit somebody who's allied with us that
gives us the right to preemptively hit
them if we do that and act on that that
automatically is then Russia's
justification for doing the same in
return to us and then if I'm US
president I have to stick to my
principle cuz if you hit us I will hit
you back 10 times harder whoever you are
and I will always keep that well then we
hit Russia 10 times harder than they hit
us that's World War right there allied
with China and by the way the the the
wild card in all of
this is you have nuclear weapons
involved we have the first nuclear
nonproliferation agreement that's absent
it's the first time we've had no nuclear
nonproliferation agreement between the
US and Russia since the early 1970s and
then China's sitting here when we're
wearing thin in Ukraine and the Middle
East to go after Taiwan which isn't our
Vital interest so again here I've done
something that no other presidential
candidate has I clear we will defend
Taiwan that's different than the US
policy in both parties right now which
is strategic ambiguity I think we need
strategic Clarity draw that red line we
will defend Taiwan at least until for
the forceable future at least until we
have achieved semiconductor Independence
because you know if China's squatting on
the semiconductor supply chain then they
have an economic gun to our head you
know you you can't be using that phone
that computer that camera these lights
we have to depend on China and ask them
for permission now one company tmsc
Lynch pin until um all of the chip Fabs
get built in the United States and the
brain power that's going to be designing
those chips are back in the United
States or at least in Korea and Japan
and the United States if you look at the
market share of global Reliance Taiwan
is the most overweight in any industry
you could ever ever lay out totally and
it's sad that we got to where we are but
we are where we are and so my view is
that that then becomes a precipitating
factor
because again it's strategic vagueness
right China doesn't know what we're
going to do versus if you say outright
no you do not do this for the
foreseeable future at least until we
semiconductor independent and after that
we will resume our current position of
strategic ambiguity a current position
resume it later this is how you avoid
World War II and I'm deeply worried that
we have and I know that was a lot going
on there and so you know there's a lot
of different factors and foreign policy
is complicated and I understand why the
likes of the neocon Hawks like Nikki
Haley would say I feel Dumber every time
you speak yep I understand you can't
process all of that because you you want
to go to war and make money and put more
money in your bank account as a
consequence of it I get that that's fine
that's why these people should never
come within spitting distance of the
White House but we are closer to World
War III than we have ever been in any of
our lifetimes in this room of those of
us who are in this
room and I think that that requires a
President Who at least states that as a
commitment and has a Clear Vision of how
to do do it and and VC funny that you
it's not funny but you were talking
right when you said uh China Russia and
that Alliance just two days ago Putin
met with the senior Chinese General and
they're hailing ties of growing military
ties that that was just two days ago and
they're doing joint military exercises
off the coast of Alaska right now
they're doing that it's literally as
it's it's it's this is people here in
this country we have been lulled into
submission so if everything I said isn't
scary enough let me just say one more
thing to wake people up World War II is
scary but I want to I want to now put a
fine point on
this this not
hyperbole if Russia and China are in a
military alliance with each other and we
enter World War II I want people to
understand what that
means that means the United States of
America as we know
it could cease to
exist okay we're with two nuclear Allied
superpowers I want people to understand
this it's not some vague idea avoid
World War III no like this country that
we know 250 years in the greatest
country I believe known to man
to secure freedom to advance human being
to allow human beings to achieve the
maximum of their potential that gift to
human history that we have the blessing
to live in today that Nation will be at
a high likelihood of ceasing to exist if
we enter World War III right now why do
I say that because that same foreign
policy establishment that led us to Iraq
and Afghanistan and spend 7 trillion and
kill tens of thousands of our sons and
daughters fighting somebody else's
War which is a mistake and don't want
that Dick Cheney ghost of the past to
come retake over the Republican party
like they're trying to with the Nikki
haly of the world who are doing it now
that same forign policy establishment as
they were doing those things failed to
protect the borders of this country
failed on Cyber defenses completely
missing failed on and I want people to
understand this with a country like Iran
could hit us with a super EMP an
electromagnetic pulse attack what does
that mean it takes out our electric grid
in a matter of days you could
have millions of Americans impoverished
instantly if our electric grid is taken
out you could have tens of millions of
Americans impoverished instantly if our
entire electric grid is taken out
space-based defenses Russia and China
both have space-based offensive
capabilities we have neither meaningful
space-based offensive or defensive
capabilities when it comes to
space-based nuclear
capabilities so cyber super EMP Space
Border missile defenses all missing so
our homeland is as vulnerable as we have
been in a long time
time Russia has actually been
accumulating nuclear weapons at a much
faster Pace way faster Pace than the
United States Hypersonic missiles that
outdate that that beat old outdated
missile defense systems against this
backdrop do you really want to March
your way to World War II it's bad enough
to say I want to send $200 billion of
our taxpayer money so that some
Ukrainian mid-level kleptocrat can buy a
bigger house because that's what's been
going on so far well with $34 trillion
in the hole over here bad enough here
and that's all bad enough but that's not
even the biggest risk here biggest risk
is at a moment where we're bankrupt
where we have no industrial capacity in
the United States and the foundation of
war is absolutely economics and and we
have the economic backbone not to fight
this war right now from an industrial
capacity standpoint but our own Homeland
is as porous and vulnerable as it is and
so there's a reason why younger people
do not like the idea of going to war
right the people young people who are
disaffected from politics you want to
pay attention right now it's going to be
a gun over your shoulder where you're
sitting in some Trench dying in a World
War III at worst even somebody else's
war that gets us there along the way if
you put the people in charge in either
party right it used to be that we would
have one party on one side and one party
on the other side of this issue now it's
even there's another Factor domestically
that could increase the risk of World
War II it's not like you have a Democrat
Party that's against a pro-war
Republican party or
a pro-american interest Republican party
that's against Wars that Democrat part
is pushing we also live in a moment now
where even as we're having this election
and tug-of-war between two parties and
you know who's going to defeat Joe Biden
and Ron McDaniel talking about defeating
Joe Biden to deflect from her own
failures as a leader here that's it's
all a deflection because both parties
agree on the pro-war agenda right now
that is another danger that increases
the risk of World War III and they say
the most dangerous ideas in Washington
are the bipartisan ones well this is the
most dangerous idea of Our Generation
and I think that the policies that
they're advancing of arming Ukraine and
other otherwise to the
teeth driving Russia further into
China's hands yes our own policy makers
are driving us into World War II where
the risk of doing so is at the highest
point it's ever been in our life and at
a moment where we could very well lose
it which means our nation ceases to
exist and there isn't a single person in
either political party laying that out
for for the American people who will be
left holding the bag suffering and
possibly dying as a result of it and the
worst part about this is the Nikki
Haley's of the world I mean she'll send
her she'll send our own Sons and
Daughters to go die so she can buy a
bigger house just like that Ukrainian
kleptocrat that's corrupt and I think
that that needs to end you you know you
know what it makes me think about when
five years ago you voted maybe not five
years ago 10 years ago when you voted
you voting Democrat versus Republican
and Republicans had the reputation of
proar party and all this other stuff and
for longest time that's what the case
was totally and then gradually 2016 2015
things changed and then all of a sudden
you started noticing this isn't about
Democrat against Republican it never got
this public remember social media is one
of the best things that ever happened
because it exposes everybody I mean a
guy like you you take social media out
you're not going to be on the debate
stage they wouldn't give it to you
because you're not so social media
became the great equalizer for a guy
like you to come out and call these guys
out today is the ultimate establishment
versus the anti-establishment vote so on
December 6 we're doing the town hall
with RFK what are your thoughts with RFK
RFK uh if you want to pull this up robs
you know on yesterday tired of Biden and
Trump 10% of swing state voters are back
in RFK he was watching a debate and he
actually liked some of the things that
you said I don't know if you saw when he
was commenting see that no yeah so what
are your thoughts about him and who does
he hurt what does this say about today's
election is he a modern day Ros Pro or
is this is a complete different case
study of an independent candidate so I I
like I like his spirit I like a lot of
his the spirit I like is the willingness
to challenge The Establishment in what
was his own party I think his commitment
to speaking about topics that the
Democratic party doesn't want him
speaking about and I think of all of the
other candidates I mean I don't think he
has offered the clarity of exact foreign
policy that that I have if I may say so
but or and I don't know that he's in the
details on this stuff but his instinct
are at least understanding that World
War II is a really bad option to the
United States so I appreciate those
things about him we have some policy
disagreements and those are less
important than what I'm about to say I
mean he has in the past I think said
things like and maybe he doesn't mean
mean it anymore but he has said things
like people who spread climate
disinformation should be put in jail
look I think the whole climate change
agenda is a hoax we can have that
discussion and let alone even if you
didn't agree with that the answer to
speech you disagree with is not
censorship and and on a good day our
knows that too you know he he believes
in affirmative action and racial
reparations I'm against a lot of that I
think it's divisive it's toxics we have
we have our plenty of share policy
agreements but at least I think his
heart is in the right place and he's
somebody who is unafraid to challenge
orthodoxies and I respect that about him
I just wish he wasn't so scared of me
why do you think he's scared of you oh I
mean the number of networks I mean you
should I I if the dates work out you
could actually offer him the same thing
I mean I can't tell you the number of
podcast Networks ET that have said hey
would you have an open discussion with
RFK I said absolutely I would do it and
every time he backs out of it and I
think
that look I think that if somebody sees
the way that I'm going after other
Republican candidates on the debate
stage I actually would not that would
not be my treatment of RFK I think we
would have in a different format more of
a conversation like you and I are having
and so I think that he I don't I mean I
I could understand why if somebody's
building their brain they don't want the
anti-establishment sheen to wear off if
you're getting you
know called out but I would my goal
wouldn't be to call him out on this
stuff we have some disagreements but
let's have actually and I think he's
probably the one person in American
politics actually put in some sense
Donald Trump in this category too but
that's about it who you can actually end
up having a conversation that's
unscripted and you could actually be
much more mutually respectful about your
disagreements and so you know i' I'd
pledge to say that if if he you know
manned up and and agreed to one of those
things I wouldn't my goal would not be
to play gacha with him I mean here's
here's just a fact of the matter is that
different people are different leaders
of different styles right I can't speak
for him but he's not in the details
right in terms of domestic policy or
foreign policy or the
how I'm a CEO by Nature I I you know
enjoy writing reading these books and
things like this and so I am a details
guy but my goal will not be to the
extent that part of his concern would be
because I'm in the details play Goa
games with him that's not that wouldn't
be the point the point would be to
actually have a conversation that
advances true discourse in the country
in a way that challenges a bipartisan
establishment that's by and large
equally corrupt and I think he gets that
and I respect him for that but I think
that you know if he's running to be
president and this man wants to to and I
I don't think he thinks or anyone thinks
he's going to I don't think he believes
he's in this to win I think he's
believes in this to move the
conversation but if he's running for
president you want to sit across the
table from xiin ping and you're an
advocate for free
speech you know I I I haven't I'm I
haven't been the one you know I mean
it's been networks that have repeatedly
been pounding both of us every time I
say yes and every time it's oh he didn't
want to do it and I think that that's a
little bit Unbecoming of him because
this is a guy I love the fact that he's
Fearless go all the way with being
fearless and know that's what I would
say and so maybe he will and so I want
to give him give him room for that but
that's all I would say is the one he'll
see this who do you think he he's a good
dude he's a good dude and he's and you
we have our disagreements but if my only
advice to him would be if you're going
to be a free speech guy go free speech
all the way don't do this climate change
misinformation censorship garbage if you
want to practice Free Speech give credit
with creditor zc makes some good points
on Ukraine glad to see some of his some
of the awareness of the Republican Party
who do you think he helps or hurts it's
a little bit
of it's a little bit of a light touch
understatement there because I think I
think the good points on Ukraine is we
got to go deep into the details and it's
not just on Ukraine but broader foreign
policy but he's he's a thoughtful guy
and so I think a lot of good would come
out of an open conversation but I just
think if you're running for US
president this applies to me applies to
everybody hold me to the standard call
me out if I'm not doing this at some
point too right and I get it because
like my sense is if you look at people
who run his campaign you got a lot of
swamp creatures from prior Democratic
establishment campaigns and I have you
know I I I I get this if you're
surrounded by an establishment that can
still shave off a little bit of the edge
I'd say bring back the inner you and
let's actually lay it out on the table
and so yeah if you talk to him I would
just my encouraging the thing I would do
and I've talked to him a couple times
this campaign I think that you know he's
he's doing a lot of important things you
guys have spoken yeah we've spoken a few
times yeah yeah and I told him the same
thing when I talked to him too is
practice what you preach when it comes
to free speech and free speech is about
a culture and an example that you set
for the country you know Barry Goldwater
I think um was it him and and JFK
whoever it was they talked about
potentially flying around the country on
the same plane you know do do Lincoln
Douglas style debates that doesn't
happen in this country anymore and I
think there's an opportunity to set a
good example but you got to man up and
there's some risk involved in every
conversation you
have but you got to take that on in a
way that advances the interest of the
country and if you want to sit across
the table from shijin ping or whoever
else and you got to show the people
you're fit enough to sit across the
table from somebody who has different
opinions than you and may have different
knowledge base than you and that's a
good thing if both people are
approaching it good I think if there's a
Leader's bulletin and who has uh agreed
to Face Off anybody the most anybody
opposing supporting anybody you're
number one okay in that I think number
two would be
RFK and then it's just everybody else is
going to become I give the santis credit
for being here Haley didn't want to be
here we invited Nikki Haley she didn't
want to come and talk on a podcast and
do a long form I don't know if she's
done any long form uh podcasts herself
it's all going to be prev vetted
prescripted you know I'm sure there'll
be a lot of rules you have to send the
questions in advance and by the way to
give credit to the SST nothing was off
table they they just said ask the
question I do give credit especially for
a guy like him where he's not naturally
comfortable doing that or at least
wasn't you know you got to give credit
with credits too I agree with that yeah
um you've mentioned she multiple times
I'm not sure if you saw the breaking
news that Biden is planning on meeting
him in San Francisco in the coming weeks
um obviously this is the most
consequential relationship in the world
you've talked about what's going on with
China um you talked about Clarity right
sort of the premise of that meeting is
they don't want any surprises they want
to have uh reestablish military
connections or re uh Communications they
want to address climate change they want
to address open borders and drugs and
fentol that's coming across drug
trafficking South China Sea what do you
envision what do you see happening with
Biden and shei next week or when it
happens I think Xi Jinping will be
running circles around Joe
Biden I think it's just it's it's a
capability issue at the top right now in
the United States of America I mean the
climate change
agenda is part of what China uses to
laugh at and trample and stomp all over
the face of the United States of America
I mean there's a word in
Mandarin it's called
bitu you know what it means refers to
Progressive white people in the United
States does apply to me some of you guys
but it's it's it's like it's like a
derisive term how do you say it it's B
AI zuo if you want if you're looking it
up so I'm not fluent Mandarin but it'd
be something like bis bis something like
that
and
so there it is yeah actually yeah it's a
derogatory Chinese neologism western
leftism western I think I think it's
actually very specific to White in
particular um Adam you're such a biso
yep yeah yeah no I don't think so no
they're referring to the kind of people
who support who support Biden actually
yeah so so and and and and to some
extent Biden falls into this category so
the climate change agenda the idea of
put thrown climate change in that this
is the useful idiot yeah in Russia right
there the modern version of the useful
idiot idiotic liberals right there
second line it is it's the Communist
useful idiot in the 19s ex so so that
when I hear climate change on that
agenda that's useless for the United
States because that's just a way for
China to run laps around us while we're
flogging
ourselves and you know I think that
that's kind of what they've done on some
of these issues of race and human rights
I mean a couple years ago what was xiin
ping saying black lives matter shows the
United States is no better when he's
questioned about putting a million
religious minorities wegers in
concentration camps and subjecting them
to force sterilization and communist
indoctrination and wors so I think that
because of that self-hatred that exists
in the United States today particularly
on the left China understands the useful
idiot the bito to be able to exploit
that psychological insecurity back
against us and because Biden is so
obsessed with self- flogging the United
States for our modern way of life and
our sins of system racism and everything
else dating back to the apologist agenda
that the modern Progressive left
Embraces that puts China at a
competitive advantage in any discussion
that looks like the one they're about to
have my discussion with Shan ping would
be different yeah I know what that would
look like yeah you Unleashed hell on the
world with the co 19 pandemic we know it
was a lab leak you lied about it the
only question is was it intentional
mhm if you don't tell me now we find out
separately there's going to be even
bigger consequences they're already
going to
be we know it was intentional because
well here's what it's going to be
Financial consequences of the highest
order using every Financial lever we
have
available if we don't hold you
accountable for that then we know we can
expect worse in the future and I'm not
going to expect worse in the future
Financial consequences using every lever
available up to including the national
debt held by China we will
extract our appropriately due reparation
for the co 19 pandemic oh by the way
you're not playing by the same set rul
are going to be kicking you out of the
WTO and any sort of relation from a
trade perspective with the US unless
you're playing by the same set of rules
no IP theft no data theft no forced
technology transfers from American
companies no turning our companies into
lobbying pawns none of that until we're
playing by the same set of rules or else
we're done and we're by the time I show
up at that meeting I'm have done my
homework we're already onshoring to the
United States and we've already
bolstered relationships with Japan South
Korea India Australia and otherwise such
that he knows when I'm sitting across
the table from him I'm not not bsing him
right we have a stronger hand than he
does that's worse for him than it is for
us he knows so then he has to fold and
he knows that but he has to know that
when he shows up which means you got to
do your homework before you show up at
that meeting the other thing I will say
is don't you touch and come
within spitting distance of the idea of
annexing Taiwan anytime in the
foreseeable future because we will
defend at least until we have
semiconductor Independence in this
country cuz you will not hold an
economic gun to our head I know that's
the wet dream that China has no we're
not going to let you do that it's not
going to happen on my
watch and then after we have
semiconductor Independence we will
resume our current position of strategic
ambiguity and see what that looks like
in the future you know this is what's
scary about this election that no one is
paying attention to it because and what
you you left out I know you didn't leave
it out you just didn't list it there
which is also tie your damn currency to
trade and Float with the international
currency markets right because they
China's manipulator number one in every
different direction but it's not just
the currencies it's manipulation of data
transfers it's manipulation of every set
of rules you're correct on every point I
was just adding currency to that I think
that if he if China senses that there is
a conservative Victory with someone's
going to sit at the table and put those
cards down they will move on China
before November 1st of next move on
Taiwan before November 1st of next year
because they have to they need that
because everything you're talking about
here says okay first of all I'm stopping
your repayments now I'm stopping on
trillions bills I'm doing this and this
and this they are they are tightened up
so many ways you're so correct they have
to move on Taiwan before the election if
someone like you is leading in those
polls you funny story I've shared this
before there was a former um leader of
of another Nation former head of state
was an event uh he approached me
afterwards he said you know they're not
happy that an indian-american and
particularly you is is running for US
president I said oh you you know that
from having known them he's like no no I
know that from knowing it now I said
okay well it's interesting to know um
you know China's you know I don't think
our adversaries are going to like it
very much if you have somebody who's in
office that can't be exploited in the
way that Biden is
however I will give the world our allies
and adversaries and our own citizens the
same message that's what makes it
credible our sole
obligation is to protect US citizens
here at
home see it's interesting how much more
credible your messages your allies can
take it more seriously your adversaries
can take your red lines more seriously
our citizens can take it more seriously
if actually saying the same thing to
everybody my sole obligation as the US
president my moral obligation is to the
Americans here at home and everything
that I'm going to draw is a hard Red
Line tracks that and that's how you know
I'm going to keep it and so they will
take it more seriously and I don't think
world war is in China's interest and I
don't think world war is in America's
interest and I don't think it's in
Russia's interest and I don't think it's
in any nation's interest and so the way
we avoid it is by having those clear red
lines clear answers about what we will
and won't do don't drive our adversaries
in different ways into alliances with
one another get Russia out of China's
hands be very clear with our own people
that war is never a preference for us
it's only ever going to be a necessity
that avoiding World War III is a vital
objective and then we protect our own
Homeland enough to say God forbid
there's a major conflict in the future
we know that we're not as vulnerable as
we are today those are the basic next
steps when it comes to foreign policy of
the next US president and then reducing
that economic dependence on China is an
easy win that we can deliver along the
way you I love that and you talk us
about serving you know us Citizens First
and one of the ways that we need to be
served right now is energy we see
fluctuations in prices we've also seen
the green lobby pushing EVS electric
vehicles cars and someone like Gavin
Newsome puts these artificial percent by
this date percent by this date out there
in the future and he's nothing thinking
about his own power grid the California
power grid is taxed right now to get
through a hot summer and they're arcing
and lighting up birds and causing their
own wildfires because they don't have
the infrastructure you have been
correctly in my view correctly talking
about nuclear energy I'd like you to
elaborate on it because if California
meets that they are selling 35% you know
um EVS in the next 5 years they don't
have the grid to plug them all in to
charge them so people can get to work
the next morning but nuclear energy
offers that and when people hear nuclear
they fear Chernobyl they fear 3M Island
that know their history books but fifth
and sixth generation nuclear power is
much different you've been clear on this
but it didn't come up in the debate can
you it didn't come up in the debate
because the other candidates in the
stage have no clue what the hell they'd
be talking about so the Republican
establishment wants to protect the voter
base from seeing that their pawns are um
you know were not prepared with those
talking points I so that's why it's not
going to come up in a republican debate
I don't think maybe not because we're
talking about it then they'll have
enough time to cycle it through and
maybe I hope it'll be good if they
include it in the next one um your
position yeah I my position is shut down
the nuclear Regulatory Commission let's
start with that the NRC has been
fundamentally hostile to nuclear energy
in the United States of America to new
nuke specifically to new nuclear power
plants and think about the result that
that yields so before the nuclear
Regulatory Commission came into
existence the average time to build a
new nuclear power plant in the United
States was about 5 years what is the
average time in a place like
Japan today around four to 5 years
France a little slower 5 to eight years
guess what it is in the United States
now after the existence of the nuclear
Regulatory Commission so anybody take a
guess what that
happens 25 to 40 years 25 to 40 years
which is a function way for a de which
is basically a way of saying just for
the environmental clearances which is
the first step of the process so
basically they've said that hey we
haven't banned the creation of nuclear
energy in the United States cuz the
American people wouldn't really vote for
that if they're educated on it but this
reveals the Dirty Little Secret American
politics the people we elect to run the
government are not the ones who actually
run the government it's the shadow
government in the Deep States so the
nuclear Regulatory Commission nuclear
energy isn't banned in the United States
but they believe there should not be
another nuclear power plant built in the
US so even though Congress hasn't banned
it they've just used bureaucratic power
through the back door to say that we
will make sure quietly through the
shadow government that there's not a new
nuclear power plant built in the United
States now why because at three mile or
Chernobyl are concerns about safety now
it's double click on
that gen 3 and Gen 4 nuclear reactors
are by any measure safer lower risk than
Gen 2 nuclear reactor and much smaller
and much smaller and more efficient and
productive because of this policy we're
not building the new safer versions of
nuclear reactors so the only ones that
are actually operative in the United
States are gen two or earlier the only
country in the world that has a Gen 4
nuclear reactor I'll let you guys guess
you think which one do you think it is
Russia China China China y for for
civilian nuclear energy so because they
have no choice so in the name of
protecting Americans what are we doing
is actually who would have ever thought
increasing the risk of further harm by
the way the FDA does this to the nuclear
Regulatory Commission the three-letter
agencies that's why my objective in
there is to get in there and shut them
down you know I I was thinking about it
I was having a interesting conversation
with somebody in the last few days how
are you actually going to lay off a
million federal employees anyway to
finish answering this question shut down
the nuclear regulatory commit
and follow the actual laws we have in
this country allow for the construction
of gen 3 Gen 4 nuclear reactors and
catch up for with the most productive
form of energy known to mankind nuclear
energy and by the way here's the
ultimate irony on
this the very people who are most
opposed to carbon emissions and I favor
more Drilling and fracking and
everything else I'm all in for
that I've been a evangelist for it but
the people who are the biggest opponents
of more fossil fuels also include some
of the biggest opponents of nuclear
energy which tells you that that climate
agenda actually has nothing to do with
the climate and has everything to do
with letting China catch up to the US
Global Equity is what they call it the
problem with nuclear energy is not that
it's not good enough at supplying our
energy
needs it is that it might be too
good at allowing the West to continue
and Us in particular to remain ahead of
China and that's what the climate change
agenda is really about it's about
letting China catch up to the US which
is why I brought that up in the Biden
xinping discussions this isn't about the
climate it's about what they call Global
equity which is a fancy way of letting
China catch up to the US that's why
China's burning more coal last year than
they ever have while the US is burning
less than we ever have in the name of
stopping carbon emissions that's why
Petrina is buying up projects that
Chevron is dropping Black Rock makes
Chevron and Exxon do it but without
causing Petrina to do it and that's why
the people who also opposed to those
carbon emissions in the US are also
against nuclear energy in the US while
China is trouncing us when it comes to
nuclear energy so anyway how are going
to shut down these agencies um you know
I've given a speech in DC on exactly the
legal Authority we would use to set shut
down these agencies and going into the
details matters but one of the ideas
I've been I've been entertaining for how
we because you know this is less of a
legal point but more of an operational
point in know business guy as well we're
talking about millions of federal
employees I got to get this job done not
in four years in the first 18 months
right because that that's really what
gives you the momentum for the rest of
your presidency you don't get that right
you're done I mean you're just you know
you'll be waiting through do some small
thing here and there but driving the big
change we want to drive I got 18 months
maybe more like six months to get
started so I think I think one of the
ideas I'm warming up to
is I need to I need to lay off at least
a million Federal bureaucrats in the
first year I I'd like to Pace faster
than that but how are we going to do
that at
scale yeah everybody has a social
security
number pick the last digit of your
Social Security
number if it's an odd number we're
keeping you and if it's an even number
you're out just do that on the first day
just that simple boom 50 I mean because
because I'm not saying it's a perfect
method but you got the law of large
numbers working in your favor right so
you're going to lose some good people
yes you're going to lose some bad people
but the law large numbers work in your
favor if you believe there's just too
many darn Federal
bureaucrats day
one if your social security number is an
even number you're
out I can almost state with certainty
that on week two of that nothing's going
to be different other than having
reduced the size of the federal employee
Base by half and my suspicion what we
will find is that's still too many
people so as I take the first number of
your social security number of who's
left and if it's an odd number we're
keeping you and if it's an even number
you're
out that's a 75% reduction then in the
federal employee
headcount not a darn thing is going to
work less effectively it's actually
going to work more effectively as a
consequence that's how you then get to
say okay this is sizable change we can
start with zerob based budgeting and
going forward we'll say what is actually
necessary I'm not even going to start
with last year's budget that the
administrative State tells us is
necessary I will start with zero as the
Baseline ask what's actually
necessary and that's how we solve the
national debt that's how we solve the
crisis of the deep State the shadow
government that's how we restore
accountability in government it's how we
make sure the people who you elect to
run the government are the ones who
actually run the government and so I I I
think there's I think that is pretty
darn close to what my plan is going to
be people how are you going to downsize
the federal government last digit of
your Social Security number first digit
and then the first digit I mean you you
may lose some guys that are credible
guys I mean I understand what you're
saying we're going to keep a lot that
still are too totally get it I
understand what you're saying but if you
cut into the muscle Patrick you can
always you can always see bring him back
like Elon brought him back yeah cuzon
fired the 50% and he's like we need
that guy we need thaty back we can
always do that I'm with you that makes
sense I'm just thinking purely as a
Twitter didn't go off the air I get it I
get it by the way it's it's funny
Twitter did not you're talking Rob can
you just put this put this up before we
go to the next stories we got a few
minutes here left nuclear energy just
helped Finland SL electric cost byy a
staggering
75% so if the average person just
listened to you and they're like dude I
have no clue he just said I'm going to
kick something here you what what you
guys still hear me no we're still on
yeah okay good I if the average person
is watching this and he I'm not
following this whole nuclear energy
we've done few episodes on this so why
doesn't the US follow suit it's got the
three reasons below one is fear one is
cost one is time
75% of electric cost the average person
listens to that and says man I'd love
that especially now that insurance cost
is going up in certain places this can
help me get some more discretionary
income but let's go to the next topic
next topic so Tucker Carlson Trump
yesterday about six months ago could
have been six months ago when Tucker
when went to uh Elon this was probably
in May yeah exactly six months ago I
said I think there's an alliance being
built between Trump Tucker and Elon
that's what I said remember I said what
are you talking about I said well Tucker
chose a retweet by Elon uh over going
anywhere else and I think it was a good
move because elon's got 160 million
followers boom that's a great place to
be and then he aligned himself with
Trump you know right before the debate
they're going out with the video got few
hundred million views on Twitter and in
yesterday Trump's being asked about
Tucker what do you think about a VP
option Trump said seriously considering
Tucker Carlson for VP okay as a VP I
don't know if you saw that I did not see
that that's very interest fascinating
that's fascinating to say the least
right one what do you think about it two
have you thought about who would be a
possible consideration for you as a VP
yeah so I think Tucker actually could be
very interesting as a choice I mean I I
think that's a
um he's one of the smartest individuals
I've met when it comes to understanding
the soul of our
country and is despite the establishment
media's attempt to paint him as some
sort of right-wing caricature he's not
actually a partisan figure at all I mean
I think many of his positions defy
partisan Orthodoxy he's an independent
thinker and I think could help rebuild I
think he he has already helped rebuild
trust in this country and so I've
been grateful for the relationship I
didn't I haven't known him for you know
nearly as long as as others in the world
of media or politics have only gotten
know him in recent years and and
particularly in maybe the last two years
but I think he's a thoughtful individual
I'd want somebody in that role depends
on what you want in the in the role you
know for me if I'm looking for an
advisor and I want it in that role I
think that he's he's not a he's not a
bad choice to be able to put in that
role and actually be thoughtful about it
I think that there's a different role
you could have for your VP which is also
an Executor and so there I might be
thinking about somebody coming from the
private sector I mean Elon Musk is he's
not a natural born citizen born in the
United States but I think he would be an
outstanding partner to have to be able
to do the thing that I just talked about
right here right which is 75%
headcount odd numbers go or even numbers
go it doesn't matter whichever
one cut number one cut number two I mean
he's a guy who's actually done it and
understand and has also built things up
from scratch and I'm an entrepreneur
he's been you know I've been more
successful than most he's been more
successful than all so including me and
so I would want the rule of thumb for me
is it's how I've built my businesses is
how I want to run this country who is
better than me in each of the domains
where I'm going to need it
okay I want to pick the areas that I'm
already the best at and still find who's
going to be better than me and that's
how we're going to have to do this not
just at the level of the VP but some of
the most important positions like the
Office of Management and budget it's
like the CFO of the federal government
you want somebody who is deep in their
understanding of actually the flow of
numbers and the flow of money who's
going to run the office of personnel
management somebody who is going to be
unsparing in their assessment of who's
actually doing a good job and who's not
it's like the HR department of the
federal
government and so for me it's it's going
to be who's going to be the who's going
to be better than me in each of those
position would you choose let's just say
cuz let's let's go there okay we had a
conversation maybe even yesterday so
okay you know how super Tuesday hey you
know Biden's number four in New
Hampshire or whatever number three Kirk
and I are talking about this in Vegas
and then all of a sudden Warren drops
out Buddha drops out everybody drop
we're all getting behind Biden wait what
he was losing what do you mean you guys
are getting behind Biden well you know
the establishment Maybe Obama called the
shots behind closed doors Buddha's going
to get this job this guy's going to do
this Warren you got to do this Boom
everybody get in a line boom we're
getting a line and they're very unified
right it's not the case with Republican
party right now and you just called that
the establishment which means let's say
the day comes let's play two scenarios
one scenario is Trump is not running
okay one one scenario is Trump drops out
which it's not going to happen well
let's just say he does if it does that
he is not running he had a massive event
to right before the debate down the
street couple miles down the street if
he's not
running Mack is not going to go go
behind Haley Mack is not going to go
behind any of those guys okay let's
combine them together say Haley picks up
Christie let's just say if Haley picks
up Christie he picks up Tim
Scott maybe they all go behind Haley or
maybe they go behind the santis okay
Maga has a choice on who to go behind
who do they go behind are they going to
go behind you yeah going be a split
between you and the S no no I mean
forget I mean the santis is is not part
of the America first movement at all I
mean I think that
he's described him put himself out as a
different type of establishment
politician what percentage of think goes
behind you though what percentage of me
goes you think 80% I think that I think
that it's it's a matter of earning the
support of our base and the Maga base
and the America first base will choose
the next president I'd like it to be
over 90% And I think that you know I
think that I'm representing the ideas
that the Maga base represents that's the
answer so and the America first base
represents putting the interest of this
country first I want to take that to the
next level right and so my view is you
know America First is going to outlive
Donald Trump I mean it's going to be
it's going to be defined nice well done
I like that I like that that's watching
K help out but go ahead I like that you
got got the got the agility it's Miyagi
son yeah I might need you you know we we
need to think about catching bureaucrats
in the federal government I want people
who are better than me right that's so
well done that's good no this is I want
people better than me is what I said for
those of you that didn't see Pat just
caught a fly he's not just m it was a
mosquito it was a mosquito I saw go
ahead you were saying you all I'm saying
is there there's two America First
candidates in this race the America
first movement will outlive Donald Trump
into the decades Yet to Come okay so my
view is that it's going to require
leaders who understand what that's all
about who are Outsiders who have the
capability to actually execute that and
translate that to action I think it
helps to have fresh legs and be from a
different generation so in this race
there's only one person who fits that
description there's one America First
Canada on that debate stage two nights
ago okay that's and it was I mean that
was dead obvious to anybody watched it
and I think I would expect and hope to
earn the support of that base to lead
this movement forward to the next Lev
what I what I loveed seeing when when
every debate happened first one when
there I me you say something right now
that's not just in that scenario right
that's right
now I want to I I want to earn the
support of that base in the next several
months before the heat of the primary
voting season begin you're talking about
America first base I got absolutely cuz
cuz as I said said before America First
does not belong to one man does not
belong to trump it doesn't belong to me
it didn't belong to Reagan sure it
belongs to the people of this country
and so you're asking about that scenario
I'm asking about I'm saying the whole
the whole
race nobody is going to become this
nominee without the full support of the
America first movement behind us whoever
that nominee is going to be there's only
two people in this race that I think are
eligible to do it that's Donald Trump I
don't disagree but let me let me go
little deeper so first debate I was
there Milwaukee during the break nobody
would come talk to you right you're kind
of like who is this guy what you don't
belong up here why is this guy here he's
been going to be done anyways I don't
know how he made it second debate you
kind of try to add Reagan try to be like
hey uh let's bring the party together
you're like no they're not going to do
that they're they backfired and attacked
you right and in third debate you're
like no here's what we're doing boom
boom boom boom but in the first two
breaks you guys got three minute three
and a half minutes right they you got
three and and half minutes go to what
you're doing and you for first two
breaks you talked to the santis for 90
seconds oh you were watching oh wow you
know more than I do he was standing next
to me yeah but you went to him which is
kind of by the way that's a sign of
somebody that's willing to talk so you
guys are hashing it out and you're able
to go talk to him what was that ex
disagreements got so that's what you're
talking we were continuing some of the
you know I I told him I told him I uh
disagreed with the law that he passed in
Florida on the you're telling him this
on stage yeah and what' he say to you he
said well I he was giving his he was giv
his yeah he was giv his argument back
but I already I mean I already knew what
that AR you seem offended though it
sounded like you guys have a civil
conversation conversation at a certain
point he he he walked away yeah I saw
that he walked away yeah which law in
Florida the abortion law the skp law so
so so disbanding student GRS disbanding
no no no no no disbanding student groups
the Palestinian the whole thing that he
talked about it on the St we talk about
on the stage I I just think that if you
go the direction of the government
deciding what speech does and doesn't go
yeah pretty soon they're going to say if
you question a vaccine you're a biot
terrorist if you you know say a j6
peaceful protester shouldn't be in
prison you're an insurrectionist
terrorist that's where this is going to
go and this road never ends well
slippery slope the question I was asking
you is I disagree with you on that is
the santis a possible like would you
consider him as a VP if if Maga goes
behind you cuz I I you've said a couple
things favorable that I think you're
being strategic here so no I mean I need
to drill I to tell you the truth I need
to understand what his capabilities
would be in he wouldn't be the advisor
type right Tucker Carlson would be the
adviser
type he
would would be a guy can he can he be
the guy Elon would be higher on my list
but Elon is ineligible constitutionally
to do it but Des sanis could he be the
guy who gets in there and guts the
bureaucracy that 75% headcount reduction
can he see that through and use the
skill sets that he's gained as Governor
knowing the executive branch of the
government to do it that would be that
would be the question I'd want to get
comfort with and if so I think it could
be an interest candidat so here's what's
crazy somebody could watch this and they
could say what an insult who the hell
are you to think you get to choose the
STIs as your VP he gets to choose if you
can you know this this whole ego thing
that but but let me just make my point
to where I'm going with this look I I
think in the next 3 to six months I
think 2024 is going to be the year of
chaos I call 2023 the year of
Investigation I think 2024 is going to
be the most chaotic year of our lifetime
okay our lifetime I don't know if we can
say our because we have some people that
are older than us at this table but I'm
going to say our lifetime here Tom we're
not talking about you I'm just kind of
putting it out there Tom has more wisdom
thank you very much respect yeah so so
here's kind of where I'm going with this
there's a few guys that are saying okay
one you know what are they going to do
what they're trying to do right now with
article three you know of him being
Insurrection they're trying to get rid
of the fact that he can't even run and
silence them and all this okay so that's
one okay the 91 felonies set them aside
but the one thing they can do that's why
these guys were brilliant to say no call
it an Insurrection this is our way to
get him to never come back and mess with
us we don't have to worry about that guy
let's just say he's out if he's
out we could wake up one morning and
you're at 6.3% we could wake up the next
morning and you're at 49% and it could
be like this it could go right but the
part I want to go right now is as of
today I think and I just want to be on
Clarity on this I think that would be
sad for the country if this is the way
they play out is try to eliminate this
man that's why I've been against we're
on the same page but chaos is chaos is
chaos but but at the same time you have
to as a be prep you got to be prepared
for all scenarios okay absolutely so two
is Wild Card Black Swan event they do
something to the man he's not one that's
not in the public he's always out there
talking you saw what a few people have
said that's possibility of what could
happen to him okay they take him out I
mean the level of temperature in us is
going to go to a whole different level
we're hoping that doesn't happen at all
has hasn't happened since Reagan and
we're up in that doesn't happen three
which is a most likely thing that
happens he is the guy okay if he is the
guy it's a different scenario for being
a second term president which is what he
would be he can only go four years yeah
so he has to be thinking about a person
to bring in to be a VP that's really
going to be the next two-term president
so you're not bringing the person in
that's going to be you know just a Mike
Pence type of guy I think it'd be a
mistake if he hires a Mike Pence type of
Personality it's going to be somebody
that's going to be vocal like a fly
carry you roll you're going around young
doing the part so a lot of people are
thinking carry Lake a lot of people are
you know thinking different names and
Tuckers down the conversation you know
for you you've said you only have
interest in one is what you've said you
only want to be the guy that's the
leader but if the opportunity Rises and
comes to you that could be 12 years of
what you could do let's just say that
opportunity comes because you have to
know guy like him he hasn't taken shots
at you yet MH there's not been any shots
we have a good relationship of mutual
respect actually for sure and that's
felt but but to me if that happened
would you actually entertain the
idea
so I'm not a planb person I me just I'm
trying I'm like I'm I'm the phase of
this campaign want to answer with total
cander but it's just my brain does not
work that way I didn't get to where I am
in life by having plan a goals and then
setting up your your bifurcated backup
plans on the important things right on
the unimportant things yeah we'll have
some plans if if I if I don't go to
lunch here we'll go to the other place
okay that that doesn't matter yeah but
the important things in life when you're
Guided by your mission and
purpose you set out and you accomplish
plan a and if you fail then you figure
it out
then but I'm not a guy who has you know
I mean I'm not saying this boastfully
but I've built successful businesses
right I built a you know multi-billion
dollar company that got multiple drugs
approved through a broken Bure ratic FDA
process challenged Black Rock built
business I'm 38 years old I'm running
for president right now my wife didn't
get to where she is by she successful
surgeon lived her version of the
American dream one of the best in the
world at what she does we made this
commitment together as a family at
immense sacrifice with one purpose in
mind it's not even winning the
presidency that's just a step along the
way to Reviving this country and our
national Soul all right that's what
we're dedicating the next phase of our
life to so we didn't do that to pursue a
plan B path along the way and
so I think it would be fake to just sort
of
say under any scenario I'm not going to
run in 2028 or I'm not going to you know
if I don't win or whatever I just am not
going down the track of you're an
athlete taking a game out of time this
is what I'm doing that's what you're
saying exact okay fair so let's go we
got n we got 11 minutes left and I'd
like to do two more things before we
wrap up one mashion yesterday gives a
speech he's not you know gonna be
running to do what he's doing but at the
same time he teases third party
presidential run in announcement that he
won't seek reelection for Senate okay
Manion is a in what state West Virginia
Republican state this is your guy you've
always talked about him so how many
people you think on the left right now
are sitting there seeing this as an
opportunity saying hey there's a chance
for me to come through here would masham
be in one would Newsome be in one are
you are you cuz you're boldly telling
everybody Biden's going to be the he's
not going to be he's not bid he's not
going to this guy's not going to do
third party I just don't think there's a
path who Manion Mansion yeah I mean oh
maybe he will but I don't think he's
going to go anywhere with that I think
that there's a version
of the world where he tries to compete
within the Democratic party but Nome
Michelle
Obama any of these other ambitious
governors in the Democratic party
Buddha kamla Harris isn't going to go
away lightly it's not going to be Biden
how convinced are you with that because
you said
that I'm very convinced it's not going
to be Biden I think they're just waiting
for the Trump trials to start and then
just slip in whoever that alternative is
going to be is it a health issue is it
the DNC stepping in is it the is it the
Bas basically saying dude we are not
voting for this guy what is it it's it's
the establishment in the Democratic
party that will decide the time has come
and Biden really is is a puppet for that
establish you don't think he has a say
in this at all I don't think he has a
say in this no I don't think he has one
iota of a say in this well and and and
the proof is the proof is how many times
have we seen on video where he says I
can't they they're telling me I can't
who the hell is they I mean there's
there's I mean the proof is countless
right you just you even without those
he's that's the part he's not supposed
to say out loud but yes there are many
instances of of seeing the fact that
this is not the man who's in charge you
keep saying Michelle Obama everyone
talks about Gavin new everyone I've
never seen her give any inkling she I
said the Republican the the Democrat
Governors that are super ambitious
they're they're the ones that want to do
it I doubt she wants to do it but they
will if necessary the powers that be
will drag her out just like the powers
that be decided that Biden's going to be
their puppet until he's not I don't see
having any appetite for this let me
throw another one here let me throw
another one here but but that you're
pretending like that's a
factor right just like just like Biden
has some say in what he's doing mean she
can say I don't want to do that they
will say you are doing it let me give
you a scenario you're let me give you a
scenario and walk me through this this
is this is one when I'm looking at
Kamala and Nome ideal Nome for the left
that he's the guy I mean they're who
they're propping up I I think that's the
likely one that's likely okay so let me
let's let's play uh Democratic political
strategist we're in the room okay it's
me you and a couple other guys and
here's what they say Vic pbd here's a
concern I know we want Nome but how the
hell are we going to do this we have to
get rid of a black woman that's standing
in front of how are you going to s make
her to VP of what if she says no I'm not
going to do she doesn't have a say in
the matter again she does not have a say
in the matter but what if she comes out
what if she comes out and she says you
don't think she will no I think that I
think that she she becomes a backtack VP
with Nome yeah interesting yeah
interesting yeah huh I think that's how
they take care of their ID very
convinced of this it's almost like
you've seen what's going on behind the
wizard of O like you like when you were
here and you did the first interview
with us what was that six months ago
then you did the town hall
you've almost been enlightened you
you've seen what's going on behind the
scene totally how convinced are you
there's this machine that's going on and
they don't have choic I'm 100% convinced
that the machine runs the show I am uh
offering a prediction that I have
reasonable confidence in but I can't say
is 100% certain right because I don't
know what the machine is going to
produce but it's the whatever is
produced it's going to be the machine
and there a machine on both sides of the
aisle absolutely so is it a fake Open
primary is it a fake Open primary how do
they how do they me mechanically do it
well the way they mechanically do it is
aligning all of the donors I mean the
mother's milk of politics is money this
is why they actually both parties have
an incentive to keep the Mega Money in
politics because it prevents the
Grassroots base from having a real say
in deciding who actually runs the show
right and Grassroots only gets the
candidates the super packs are held by
the big Treasure Chest the RNC DNC
that's right exactly and so because
money's the mother's milk that's kind of
the one lever they hold and then the
administrative state that actually runs
the show I mean Biden's not really the
president it's the shadow government
Underneath Him have a lot of levers and
then they use use hard power too I mean
you know that documents case you haven't
heard about for Biden for a while right
yeah not at all yeah but but it's kind
of hovering there it's not open it's not
closed interesting how that works got a
little bit of little bit of some
independent Council thing going on with
Hunter Biden maybe that govette yeah
yeah but but but the case but the case
is hovering too right so there's the
hammer right I mean if the guy does have
a Moment of clarity and decide well I'm
not that's when the documents Cas is
before we wrap up we and and and they
got the perfect air cover cuz that's
what they we we got it on Trump and so
it even legitimized is the Trump
prosecution because say and now we're
applying in a bipartisan manner against
Biden that's what they're saving it for
so people got to see it's not
Republicans and Democrats this is the
real game and you got to be able to see
it for what it is that's what's
happening five minutes left okay guys if
you're watching this Vic has two books
nation of victims and he's got I didn't
come here to
promote I didn't even know they're going
to be here both of these books are going
to be signed there's a questionnaire
there actually are signed both of these
books are signed two of you are going to
get it there's a question there's a link
you can click on it at the top the chat
it's a question if you've been following
the whole thing we talked about one
thing if you get the question right and
you're one of the first to do it we'll
send these two copies to we'll announce
it by the end here's my question for you
just for the record I did not put these
books up we put it there we put put it
fact I'm taking here's here's a question
from a user it's a good question that's
watching fad Malik question for VC legit
glad we had someone who will fight for
America First what would you say you
would do for people under Deca you know
most of them have lived their entire
lives went to school work for the US how
would you help them out is it the
dreamers to be clear yeah yeah so I I I
uh this is this is a hard question okay
so anybody tells it's an easy question
is just lying to offering a glib
response I don't blame many of the
people who have entered this country
illegally under Obama or Biden when you
have a
president that has effectively given you
a wink and an odd in permission to come
particularly Biden
however We're a nation founded oh his
brother's here his brother's here oh
we're good we're Nation founded he's the
last one was the LA odd number ending in
Social Security the first one it starts
got phase two got phase two coming right
here so so so the short answer is and I
think we got a roll we're um you know I
don't we're having too much fun but I
think I can feel my phone buzzing which
means they say 11:30 we're about to W
okay okay got it
so
anyone who's in this country illegally
if we're thinking on the time scales of
History I think has to be returned to
their country of
origin against the backdrop of at least
for those who have demonstrated
themselves to make real contributions of
this country and abide by the rule of
law to have a legal and a reformed and
sensible legal path to
immigration if I'm in the white house as
a father of two sons I have i' have an
awful hard time looking my two sons in
the eye and telling them you have to
follow the rules if the government that
I am leading doesn't follow its own
rules and so it's with a it's
with empathy compassion we will be as
respectful we will never separate
families and we'll take the whole family
unit and have a legal path back for
anybody who meets the standards of legal
immigration one of the ways you could
have meet that is to meet the standard
of saying that if you've already been a
law-abiding citizen and you've
demonstrated and made and made made
useful contributions and have skills
that can continue to contribute to the
country in the way that any other legal
immigrant would then there's a legal
path back in but I think if we're
thinking in the time scales of History
the long run to say we are a nation not
founded on ethnicity or on a Cuisine
We're a nation founded on a set of
ideals that's what unites us and one of
those ideals is the rule of law then we
have to stand by those ideals and mean
it not just when it's easy but when it's
hard and that's the way I'd lead as
commander-in chief and I and I the
person asked that question may not agree
with what I had to say and I and I
respect
that but that's where I would land and I
would lead nonetheless with compassion
and dignity for every person
involved and make sure that we handle it
after we've done the first step which is
making sure if you're in this country
illegally you can't be here got to
respect the fact that you're being
honest here's the winners uh Jason uh
Nolasco you get one of the copies
Brandon if you want to send me the other
one or Rob we'll give the announcement
here as well uh aside from that it's a
pleasure having you on as usual RFK if
you're watching this I'll message you
afterwards to see if you're open to the
ID or not if those of you guys want to
see him in RFK cut that clip put it on
Twitter tag RFK tag vivec I'm sure vivec
his Camp's going to be seen that as well
and maybe we can make that yeah I I
don't forc this but if people have asked
be a great conversation between the two
of you and I think we could Davi Jenkins
is the other winner that we have for the
book we'll send that over to you
December 6th RFK Town Hall 5990 live you
can register take care everybody have a
good one bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye thank
you
guys